i haven't done this in a while
yeah well i'm so i'm i'm both sober and
not hungover so there's a win
that's good yeah we'll count those how
many times is troy going to vomit on
this episode
jesus purely conversationally
he changed the game he changed the game
did i yeah what game did i change just
gave the game a podcast thing you just
you redefined it no there's been all
sorts of things where people have thrown
up like derek waters had that whole you
know that that
have you ever seen that viral local news
clip from like 30 years ago um
this was a big this was a big thing when
i was
in college and it was on like you know
the youtube predecessors like e-bombs
world
where body bombs there was a guy who was
uh
on a local news
interview where he's at the desk with
the anchor like they have him seated
right there next to them and he's super
nervous being on camera and he keeps
talking really slowly and then he just
loses it and vomits all over the desk
and the they're like
and he and he just keeps his head down
and shaming he just goes i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry and then they just cut away
that was that was the
that was a president that threw up on a
dignitary it's like that was what we did
in the 90s
bash
i i guess it was early two thousand i've
told you that i get migraines um yeah
and my migraine's very bad and i vomit a
lot when i get them and i often don't
want to miss work meetings because i
don't want to feel like i'm behind so if
i ever have a migraine on a work day i
just turn my camera off and i sit in the
bathroom and vomit
while still in the meeting i think you
should keep the camera off but
microphone on so everyone can hear it
yeah
a lot
i'm getting surgery to attempt to get
rid of the migraines in two weeks what
is that surgery because
surgery lobotomy they are cutting my
nerves
cool
so i had to have like a whole bunch of
scans and [ __ ] and i
yeah i'm having my forehead cut open
basically something's really wrong you
know your brain has no sense of pain
right there's no pain receptors in your
brain what causes headaches in general
typically it's dehydration that's why
that's mine
where is the pain then
i would think it would be
uh
yeah not not actually in your head but
uh it's caused by dehydration but there
is a swelling that's happening your
brain but that's why i was just
listening to a podcast about this where
they can and you see this in uh uh what
was it a red dragon where he like cut
his head open you know and was just like
cooking his brain right in front of him
um
they your your pain has no receptors so
you can actually just like if you watch
severance they did the same thing or
this one right in the back what you
drilled
was sorry i thought you were going to
spoil separate stuff no i'm only like
four episodes in oh it's so good does
your brain have watching herbs
i don't know i'm not even right
yeah it's entirely made of nerves
it is just one
giant organ does brain have nerves does
brain have nerves it is it has no
pain receptors no keyceptors the nerves
that detect damage or threat of damage
that seems very
anti or counterintuitive to evolution
this is legitimate that's kind of the
point of this feels no pain
that's why there's a skull otherwise
we'd just be walking around floating
brains
well the the
the
the the pain receptors on your head
if anything gets past
them
it's kind of a done deal at that point
anyway austin can you do me a favor
that's true can you push your glasses
back
there we go
does the brain contain
cranial nerves there are 12 pairs of
nerves that originate from the brain
itself these nerves are responsible for
very specific activities and are named
and numbered as follows
olfactory whatever smell so obviously
the nerves in your brain are very
important to your entire existence they
just can't
feel pain
most headaches are muscle strain right
most emotional like nor normal headaches
are often caused by like neck your neck
muscles kind of tensing against stuff
that's what i've heard you know what's
funny is
related to that that's how your muscles
attach up there poor exercise
can also be sorry poor diet and lack of
exercise can also cause headaches
somehow
you know how when you drink something
really cold and you get
a cold headache yeah that that
cold headache who calls it cold
headaches
it was always called when i was growing
up
nobody's ever said that show of hands
brain freeze i've also heard it has been
even the british guy
is very thin
we heard a word of it in the uk
what the hell are they doing in colorado
cold headache
headache it's a cold headache but that
either way brain freeze sorry to offend
your texas sensibilities yeah uh
the um
the
i was recently googling this because i
i had this kind of thing kicking around
in the back of my head that
scientists still don't fully understand
what's going on there when you
experience that it's one of those
phenomena that's
like there's prevailing guesses but
they're not a hundred percent confident
in what's actually going on when that
happens which anytime you come across a
thing like that
i always find
interesting this is that's right they
don't understand how bees
exist
that according to us
these exist because they're
they're necessary for the
and a daddy propaganda fell in love that
would be my assumption where most bees
come from more like a bunch of daddy
supposedly
according to
physics bees should not be able to fly
because they're they're they don't
understand how bees fly yes their body
mass versus wing span versus i guess
muscles that would support wings
scientifically don't add up
not confident in the source any time an
article says this violates physics i'm
my skepticism uh goes into overdrive can
that be a quote on our next trip i think
scientists need to find their energy why
are you bothering me i guess that it was
my physics do bees violate physics let's
find out
all this podcast has become is is a lot
of googling [ __ ]
i've always wanted to be oracle
yeah
wait which oracle
uh the batman batman one yeah are we
gonna talk about gotham knights i
haven't watched it yet i will right
after this i haven't watched it yet but
we can what would you like to see are
you in that one troy or i'm not
um but i mean this is the the
long-awaited like warner brothers
montreal
yeah i'm i'm playing gotham you're
playing gotham
[Music]
it's gonna be great gotham you're saying
about montreal you sound about the
montreal no i mean because just think
about this those guys have have been a
bit you know
quiet
for some time
sometime cooking up this presumably well
but it's gone through multiple
iterations right i mean the team has
changed there's there's been uh which is
which is often the case you know you
ship a game and and people
go or they get promoted or they leave or
they start in new studios or whatever
but it just um
for
that studio to still retain
something within that that license which
i i guess i don't know how that license
would work maybe mike you know this
because there's there's batman and then
there's
all the derivative stuff from that right
so that was warner brothers
i mean it is wb montreal but it's also
interesting that so they own it's their
ip basically yeah but gotham knights
also currently exists in three separate
formats without the that exact same
titling and they are not into each other
comics the cw show
and the game
and they are they are not actually
overlapping at all
well we're in the area of the multiverse
now so none of that matters
that was always the thing that was
really impressive about arkham asylum
was that they intentionally
just didn't attach it to any existing
canon but cast actors from different
versions yeah but i mean the first one
did right the first one was a little bit
more too true to the graphic novel yeah
it was a far more expanded version of it
i mean not in there there is no version
yeah and there were definite key moments
where they were like hey we have to have
the whole thing where he smashes his
hand in the glass but think about the
era like think about like like like that
could very easily have been like a a
nolan movie universe tie-in game and it
would have come out in one game and we'd
never see any more but because they
because they distanced it they have so
much more longevity right yeah i don't
think they're doing tie-ins anymore i
don't see that happening you know what i
mean like harry potter is not fantastic
beast it's harry potter right so it's
yeah you're right it would make perfect
sense to do that as fantastic beasts but
they're not but there i did there was no
matrix game and clearly that could have
been something that they did it's
because the film people realize that we
can expand their ip rather than just
making a tie-in like that's the there's
a there's a lot more respect in
hollywood now for gamers do you
isn't that what's going on with the
obi-wan show that like aren't there
aren't the characters that they showed
in the trailer or originating from
the respawn game um i mean oh yeah
mandalorian is full mandalorian's got
like the droid from jedi fallen order
it's got the um those droid soldiers are
from
they reference a battle that was created
for the battlefront 2
yeah game and and that was like i think
the first time a a live action show
a live action star wars thing had
sort of blessed the canonic presence
they're absolutely right for everything
now ip's everything so they're anyone
who can generate is very valuable i have
a question too do you think that it's
also just a out of a
sheer necessity because the the before
you could pretty much put a game
together in six to nine months you would
crunch like crazy but you could do it
and now just given the demands of of how
it what it takes to make a triple a
console title
you can't do a movie tie-in asylum yeah
was
20 months to make
40 people originally
but ended up with 60.
this is killing me because i literally
have a book on them
that's good grabbing it right now oh
yeah it went from 40.
i was like two years
where's the rest of you was like no
we're just a small studio like
but i think they're still in the same
building like they're it's it's
it's not a huge huge smartly it's a
smartly scoped game like from a like
again like other game developers look at
arkham asylum go you clever bastards
again like it seems obvious now because
it was so successful but like doing a
batman game all in one location all with
very specifically similar sure bad guys
like but that was it's very exciting oh
eight
oh no it would have come out in 2008 i
think it was started about yeah i think
it was 2008.
so i mean i i just don't think that you
can do i don't think you have the the
the the runway well even goldeneye was
like
like that was in the 90s and gold and i
was supposed to come out as a movie
tie-in and was late right they couldn't
even deliver that on time and i feel
like yeah i mean you're right that it's
a shift that i've never even thought
about that we don't get that stuff
anymore but i also wonder if
it originally came from movie execs
thinking it would be beneficial and then
realizing that that doesn't that
marketing doesn't actually work that way
we were promotion games were a
promotional item for a movie rather than
an expansion and an extension of the
franchise like you know the the the job
part why they were always terrible yeah
they were always there
talking to each other
in the store the other day the dvd of
dramatic three and on the back on this
making of features they've got you know
some promotional material for our game
you would never have seen that like the
idea of like
we're now you know they're they're kind
of doing that kind of cross-pollination
well can we ask about the timing of that
then mike the timing of of with john
wick specifically
was that were there conversations if you
can talk about it regarding like we want
to come out around this movie or was it
just when it was done
um well we definitely like when we where
we i'm trying to remember now it's been
a while oh no genuinely like when we
started obviously you you try and
schedule the game and work it out but no
there was no they were they were very
much in the opinion of like make it good
um because i think because that's the
other thing is the people who are now
running these kind of relationships um
the people at film studios who are
making games they played games as kids
so they remember all the crappy times
that were playing now too
so i think they they definitely yeah
there wasn't pressure to release the
only the only kind of uh the movie stuff
was just like hey we've got you know the
third movie's coming out do you you know
you should probably tie some kind of
promotion we came out though i think we
came out a little bit after the movie i
don't think we we weren't in the release
window for the movie we were kind of i
don't know but you know we we tied our
announcement was close to the movie and
stuff so there was some overlap there
but no it wasn't
they they are not no one's seeing this
stuff anymore as like you know john wick
three isn't gonna do better because my
video game came out you know what i mean
like it's not they don't it's not
promotional at all in that way it's it's
more but it might go the other way
around right like if the game is a huge
if the movie was a huge flop uh the game
probably would suffer some aftershock of
that possibly yeah yeah that's
reasonable that's fast but i don't think
it's really ever happened in the inverse
i i remember we did
yeah i think so
i don't know i can't remember spy hunter
actually was ever a movie was that a
movie with with uh the rock
with the wrong that seems like a film
that exists or am i doing like some
because they were supposed to be it's
been
i think the diesel is attached at one
point
do you want me to oh it was the rocket
can you give me your best batman
please i'm still i'm still on the beach
computer
i played the [ __ ] out of the spy 100 ps2
game so much fun
um
but then there was also we did eon flux
that was a movie tie-in and they would
not tell us what the plot was they
wouldn't tell us anything so our story
was so
vastly different that was the error
right there yeah jurassic park games
that
are
that take the plot from the novel rather
than the movie so there's like a bunch
of jurassic park games with scenes in
them that are not in the film but were
in the book because they were all based
on the book
it's nowadays no we had like we were i
was re i read the john week three script
before they started shooting and we had
full access to that i think there's
there's just much more access now and
much more understanding you know i had i
was you know i could i met with like the
filmmakers and stuff to get asked them
questions about anything that was vague
or whatever sat in on the edit like
there's there's room as i recall they
gave you firearms training
yes i got yeah close quarters combat can
come through chad chad showed me a bunch
of ballistics youtube videos it was a it
was a journey that project was an
interesting project
but the the thing about star wars
specifically like if there are jedi
fallen or italians to obi-wan or
whatever is that
they're so involved from the jump in a
way that i don't know that anyone else
is in part because of that lucas like
secrecy [ __ ] that they have going on
like i have friends who've worked on
star wars games and it's like we want to
do this planet and we would like it to
look like this and then they submit it
to somebody and somebody says no because
this is like something in this thing
that's not out yet so you can't do that
like they everything goes so far up a
chain that it seems like it would be a
nightmare right on one of those games
but it also means that they can
comfortably have everything be part of
the same cohesive universe except for
all the [ __ ] they throw out i guess
yeah you're i think i think yeah it's i
know and that's that's exciting that's
cool that like typical imagine if you
were the the concept artist who came up
with that fallen order droid and now
you're seeing it in
mandalorian that's you'd be i'd be over
the moon about that that's right yeah
manny uh hugopian was the one who like
gave um bd bd1 bd1 i think i think i
think
i
think
i
think
i
think
i
think
i think i think i think i think this one
right his backstory and now he's got
like action figures and stuff and that's
so [ __ ] cool
the buddy of mine is a vfx artist who
was working at ilm on the force awakens
and
was told
by
the you know i don't remember if this
came directly from jj abrams or was just
kind of like through the pipeline but he
was basically told
um
here's a shot of a desert
put some wreckage in it so he put the
star destroyer stabbed down into the re
into the desert which became the opening
shot of the first trailer and arguably
the most iconic image i think of the
entire sequel trilogy
and he just was trying to make something
that looked cool
and i had to do the math on that that
sounded weird he was like there's a uh
there's a there's a whole novel like
they they hired an author to basically
write a novel about that star destroyers
crash and final battle and la and he was
like how crazy that
basically i i designed a shot and just
basically tried to make it look good and
honor you know the past star wars like
you know designs and blah blah
and then it has now spun off into a
thing i have a question first i have a
comment i really want someone to just do
a mashup of every time we all just
converge on to the same on-ramp of
conversation how we all just like
collide
because we're all
wanting to comment or something we
always go i just know go ahead
you could do a three-hour super car
sorry
three hours
three hours so i mean 101 episodes um
but to that point
in the age of like protecting artists
and making sure that artists are
recognized for their hard work and
making sure that any derivative you know
content that is created off of someone's
art that they make even though it is
just a
it's a work for a higher gig you know
that that
he doesn't own the star destroyer he
doesn't know anything about that it's
just something it's his design
someone who writes a character for a
game let's say it's a
a mid-level writer at a
mid-level studio that happens to do a
star wars game
that didn't necessarily perform that
well they had a contract for 10 months
they write they create a character and
then somebody played that game who's now
a showrunner on the next big star wars
show takes that character and he's now
the new mandalorian or they're doing
something with that character we've seen
that happen with rosario dawson there's
like so many characters they're now just
like
flushing out this universe it's already
so packed with characters and story but
now it's a huge thing and like you said
now you've got
all sorts of things you have
a spin-off series that has merchandise
that also has a game tie and everything
else
at some
is that writer entitled to something or
i mean i'm not saying contractually but
this is a it's a really
interesting just props
yeah i mean like the most work for
higher contracts their whole point is
to not have a elaborate difficult paper
trail
expand like
you know music is one of the interesting
quasi-loopholes of a lot of that because
usually even if
if it's a work for hire
there are still potential pathways for
annuities or royalties yeah to earn yeah
turn royalties through what's called
public performance
so like if um but
part of why i think credit's so
important like i i think that you can
work wherever and make the thing you
made and then
ign still uses my vo at gamescom on
their booth and it's really weird to me
that i don't work there anymore but they
still get to use my voice to advertise
very strange but they're allowed that's
content that i made for them while
working there but
this is why
i think credit especially in games is so
important i'm totally gonna butcher the
reporting of this which makes me feel
bad but um
uh the woman who named uh rivet in
ratchet and clank um
there was a cdc thing right yeah had a
tweet thread where basically she was
like very much erased uh from the
conversation surrounding her input i
think she was a lead
on that project and they were like yeah
so we all got together and
you know we just kind of came up with
rivet but it was fully her that came up
with it so she's nothing
full of men
with one woman in their men all thought
they came up with an idea that actually
yeah
however i do think men in the game
also have their credit removed
but but you're right
that reminds me of the time that mike
brought up the rivet or i did it yeah
it's a really interesting not again
but it's that that's the thing that's
like you're saying sorry
you have been booted from the car
now i'm here by myself uh talking to
myself you can't expect uh to talk about
myself money for the thing that you
contractually did for a company or
compensation in that way but i do think
that we should be crediting people
properly in video game credits even if
they leave before a project ships and
credit your peers for the stuff that
they actually came up with otherwise you
you just suck
is that just for a hey we want to give
you credit or is it so that it would
trigger a payment because i
i think it can trigger a payment in so
far as it can help you uh get further
get more opportunities yeah sure
i'm of the mind of that
i feel like there's
i'm speaking purely for myself obviously
um
i i believe that um
every every job is connected
so if i do a [ __ ] job on this job
i can't just walk away and go oh well
because i will never know who else is
working on that that witnessed my poor
performance or my poor attitude and goes
there's been a lot of people that are
like don't work with that guy because
he's an [ __ ]
and they were right they were i was an
[ __ ] on that thing and i needed to
learn how to change my attitude and work
better with people so that my
performance and the game could have been
fine because there's 300 people that are
making sure that it's not [ __ ] when they
ship it out the door that doesn't mean
that the what i put into it at the time
was not worth it there's a lot of people
internet probably agree with me but i
definitely think that
giving somebody credit for something
that they did is fine but most people
that i've seen
who are concerned with getting that
credit
operate from such a place of fear that
are afraid that this is the only job
they will ever get and it better pay
them everything that they can get
because there's nothing that's coming
and for some people that's very
yeah
know if we true
yeah i just don't know if we can
separate the hey we want to give you
credit without someone going well what
is that worth
i think i think people i think being
incredibly being as generous as possible
with credit is in no way harmful to
anyone like there are people creating
our games who've done like three hours
work like and good on them
i don't i don't think it necessarily
implies that money needs to be involved
i don't think i don't think a credit
implies are you speaking from the
position of the developer position of
the employee well i i think i think well
always both but i think um i mean if
someone's credited on a commercial
product they should have been paid for
it but that's not what you mean right
you mean being paid in addition like
royalties
sure i think that there's there's been a
situation where someone did some work
and then it um
that work ended up getting used in some
derivative content they were like hey
i'm i i should get something for that it
was literally a lawsuit to that exact
end that was just recently
uh
officially quoting
uh
amicably resolved but
um
marty o'donnell composer of the halo
majority of the halo series sued
microsoft
along with his co-writer and and
collaborator mike salvatore
because they basically stopped crediting
them along the way and like their this
halo tv show is dropping using their
music in the ads and they're seeing
nothing for it seeing no
credit no mention and their argument was
you know we signed a deal
um that that gives us
the right to this uh you know credit and
royalties they they they explicitly said
you owe us a lot of unpaid royalties
because we signed that deal in a
different era of the game industry than
within the kinds of terms that uh might
be
might be familiar now and none of it was
i don't think the terms of their
settlement were made public but marty
did tweet it's been resolved
um
which
but that's the lesson hopefully means
they got some kind of nice payout
because they're literally
they're using this material to advertise
the ip and and and the contract didn't
prevent that what are you saying mike
so or i'm sorry
i think it was a lana no i i interrupted
you i was saying that um that's the
lesson for young folks entering the
industry is contracts
like i agree
get a contract get it in writing if
you're not comfortable with the wording
of a contract it's okay to kind of
challenge it
it's so hard to do that when you're
desperate for work though too so i know
i know 100 is but like may i speak
because there's no there's no well just
let me finish this one with with the
with the with the marty o'donnell thing
it's like there is no case there is no
there is no back and forth or legal
thing if there wasn't something in
writing the industry doesn't operate
unfortunately on like fairness or the
right thing it ultimately comes down to
what you have on paper and and
that's unfortunate i i don't think that
it's a failure of human goodwill that we
have
that we formalize the process to make
sure that if there's a if there is like
if there's let's say there's a internal
regime change at a studio and they're
looking for ways to
um you know save money because the
company is you know on a downward spiral
or something yeah no i meant it more i
mean in the abstract sense that it's a
shame that we need contracts in order
for people to get what they're owed as
opposed to just being people just
wonderful people
i still would challenge that from the
standpoint if only in my experience i
signed a lot of different types of
contracts yeah and i every week my whole
mo is i want to make a deal that feels
good to whoever i'm making the deal with
like you know some people some people
are all about you know especially indies
like yeah let's let's work out a revenue
share deal let's let's find some way to
to share in the action then there's a
lot of kind of middle grounds and then
there's obviously the more uh you know
work for hire just
maximize your upfront pay because it's
one and done and all of those have
acceptable variations and i've signed
variations on just about every type of
contract out there i can't remember the
specifics like when a project comes up
and i think
this probably could be modeled on the
deal i did for x or y i have to go look
up and even remember what i
agreed to being able to have a point of
reference that you both yeah objectively
look at that's that's
it would be nice if people were just
good to each other sure but we agree
with contraceptives
yeah
that's the thing i just don't consider
it like it doesn't mean it's evil
i come across the sentiment all the time
from young composers that that part of
the value of contracts is because evil
producers are always trying to [ __ ] the
talent and i am like i don't know who
all these evil producers are because
while i've had the occasional
points of disagreement or difficult
projects generally speaking everybody's
just trying to ship the thing and doing
and everyone has their
point of reference on ways to get it
over the finish line and that does
occasionally lead to
you know ruffled feathers but like
it's a weird conspiracy theory of you
know
the
poor delicate flower creative talent is
always under the boot of the people who
are who are you know
in charge and i'm like it's at minimum
it's more complicated than that and i
thought
you know that's not the point i was
making i know but i'm just saying it it
sort of happened
it would be nice if both parties
were just fair point i'm running point
is just everyone be nice um but i'm in
agreement
i like a contract i did have something
that we'll get to what troy was gonna
say i did have something happen recently
that it was so [ __ ] up that it was
laughable somebody owed me uh my own
content i agreed to do something for
them and in exchange they would give me
the thing that i made on their premises
or whatever and so i was waiting for
this thing for them to give me that they
said they would give me and then they
were like
actually here's a contract we're only
going to give it to you if you promote
this thing for us
after all of these email threads i was
like are you [ __ ] kidding me
thankfully they backed out but i was
like shocked by how absolutely terrible
that was but that that kind of speaks to
my point where
i you said this that's the lesson right
is that contracts are good i i feel that
trying to go back and go hey this thing
that i did is now a lot more successful
than we thought it was going to be so
where's mine as opposed to okay on the
next one i want to learn from that and
apply that wisdom and go hey in the
event that this thing is really
successful can we both agree that
there's something else that we could do
i'm fine for that it's it's when we come
back and go
wait a minute i
i deserve more than that because this
thing it ended up becoming a success was
like yeah but it could have also failed
it happened with squid game i believe
that the
creators
didn't make very much money
uh
from that original series that netflix
did not even project to perform that
well but now we'll make money on the
next thing is the idea for sure and
hopefully they negotiate the same thing
too i do just very quickly want to speak
to um uh desperation um i do not in i
want to be very very careful how i frame
this
um because i do not believe that poverty
is a state of mind i do not believe i
believe that there are there are
definite people that are in
circumstances and situations
um both internal and external that put
them in different financial positions
that put them in different circumstances
that
can
make them or allow them to choose
different things than i would have or
whatever so i'm not speaking
specifically to that what i am specific
speaking specifically to are people
who are starting off in an industry
no matter what level of talent or no
matter what level of
um success they have
when desperation creeps in
that is 100
whenever i've been desperate it is
because i have been afraid
and i've been forecasting falsely what i
believe my future is going to be as
opposed to what my future is will this
be my last job i don't know but the the
reality is that i do have a job right
now will the next one follow i don't
know but if i allow myself to become
desperate about whether or not i will
get another job or whether this job will
pay me enough
i'm no longer in this job and that is a
that is a poor performance to the people
that have currently employed me and that
is when i have lost
this job that i currently had for fear
that it would be my my last if you're
doing good
you find yourself in partnership with
people that are equitable and amenable
to you and your talent and your
abilities you will continue to work
every year i start over from scratch
austin's the same way mike is a
self-made person and so are you alana
all of us have been you know what i mean
like all of a sudden
from somebody else i don't like the word
self-made i'm the product of several
several things that i'm not responsible
for
you put yourself in a position to be
able to receive the good graces of even
people that that gave it to you the
charity brothers put me in several
positions that gave me a good so anyway
it's fine
i know where you're coming from
i i work i work hard but it's it's
nothing is handed to me at the beginning
of the year or even at the end of the
year it's like i have to go out and find
it i have to go out and either audition
or build relationships or or continue to
do good work but the second that i allow
myself to feel desperate i'm just at a
deficit for the job that i'm currently
doing so i just want to encourage people
yeah
don't don't if you find yourself
acting out of a place of fear
um i don't think you're doing yourself a
good service to the to the career that
you're trying to build that's all i'm
saying yeah you'll make a bunch of
stupid choices really uh yeah like an
example
[Music]
i was not paid very well
and i remember
again contract they could do whatever
they wanted but i was also on a visa
meaning that i couldn't quit lest i be
deported so they obviously knew that
that i didn't want that i also just had
no real bartering power for anything
because visa
um
you own my
right to be in the country and i
remember i i still don't think they have
very good uh talent agreements but
there was a sponsored thing that i had
to do on top of my regular job uh
because the publisher asked for me
specifically and then i was told that
ign was paid like 120 000
for that and i got none of that and that
always seemed very unfair to me from a
media perspective of like if somebody is
requesting me specifically
and i have to do it
extra work hours on top of my job to be
able to do the thing and i don't get a
cut of that wasn't in my contract
because that was just a product that ign
made and i was an ign employee but that
always felt very unfair exploitative
yeah the a perfect example of troy
saying like
you roll into the next contract
knowing that the the things that you
don't get to do this yeah everyone on
these calls signed a terrible contract
at some point i know oh my god
[Laughter]
you were always i i i will not endorse
that statement uh i i always felt well
when i first joined rooster teeth um
they were able to sell merch with
people's names spaces quotes slogans and
not give those people money but that
changed while i was working there which
seemed like a very correct thing to do
was that if any merch was sold with your
face on it or something you said on it
or a joke that you came up with or
whatever then you would automatically
get a cut of sales but initially they
didn't do that because they still own
all that content they can do whatever
they want with it it's very weird
one of the most eye opening for me was
um
they're in in this is probably true in a
lot of freelance freelance type
contracts
um but it's certainly relatively common
in composer
land and i always recommend it to young
composers is to have
um
like termination
language
that that is associated with the
cancellation of a project like
if you're fired depending on the
circumstances of your being fired that
usually has a tendency to basically give
them the right to wash their hands of
you but if the thing is canceled or
you're somehow let go
through no breach
there
there's surprisingly little by default
that tends to go into those if you just
ask like for 10 sample contracts
and i had it i had it once where a
project i was working on got canceled
there was no what do we do if this thing
gets killed from the producer's side it
just goes away but you know you you you
make time on your calendar you do but
the payments are often associated with
milestones of development which means
now we fall short of that so i guess i
just am out of luck
so so on the next contract my agent and
i were like we're definitely going to go
ahead and put in some
some um
cancellation language including a fee
associated with if they terminate the
contract yeah and the next thing that
came up where we had that language in
there they hired me and then before i
could write one note the publisher
canceled the game and i got paid for
literally doing nothing um and i was
like that is the best defense of this
contract language i've ever seen i've
worked with uh somebody who got recast
and the
the publisher uh and may have just
originated from the developer out of the
good graces were like hey this isn't
fair to you it's it's our
it was our lack of ability to be able to
prop we changed the character on you
essentially and so that it has nothing
to do with you did and they paid him out
and i i would tag on to this
be wary of anyone who isn't willing
to
have a contract with you or speak to
representation of yeah if people like
come on let's just keep it friendly
we're like we're keeping it friendly and
the friendly way to do this is for us to
have a document that just points out if
we ever get confused five years from now
what do we do
just be wary of those people for an
episode about credit i need to give
appropriate credit too sam max
um
who
was the that was the russian blank one
yes i just wanted to make sure that i
actually properly give her credit um so
sam tweeted saying this is a fun piece
that goes into detail about she's linked
to nigerian article about how we
developed rivet though it's pretty
upsetting and frankly offensive that
they never once mentioned me given i was
lead writer and responsible for a ton of
this development and then um she goes on
to talk about how a gdc talk makes it
sound like a bunch of the stuff sprung
up out of nowhere or a bunch of the
stuff about rivets sprung up out of
nowhere when she was one of four people
there and she was the one who said we
can't call her ratchet she suggested
gadget and rivet et cetera et cetera
and they basically just completely
erased her from that conversation do you
think that part of this may
yeah
here's my attempt to charitably see how
that may have happened
just i don't know i i don't know any of
those people we can i have no reason to
doubt that it isn't just some
you know
callous overlooking of of of a teammate
but but out of curiosity from your
various perspectives
it would seem to me that a lot of
developers work hard to feel like we're
a unit the team made this
as opposed to a kind of heterogeneous
mixture of a lot of individuals like
other than maybe a leader you know a
figurehead who's like the top of the you
know like a ted price you know like
someone or a neil druckman you know
someone who's kind of the the the acting
director of the overall operation
it would seem that
there's a lot of emphasis on
you know
the studio did this and does that lead
to a sense of kind of nameless we didn't
this could be done politely like
numerous ways that you could be in
interest of brevity they're just like
and then it came together um or what
you're saying which is making it like a
team um but i don't like as a conscious
choice for studio culture or whatever
potentially but i don't think that's
necessarily the right thing to do for a
lead writer who came up with the name of
the law no no i'm not i'm not i'm not
but yes i don't think that necessarily
is that how it could have gotten there i
don't think they are inherently evil
you've got to remember as well well
you've got to remember as well a lot of
that the intentional kind of
making it the team rather than the
individual
that's often uh you know it's the the
corporation is incentivized to make
people think often comes from the public
if you're if you're yeah if you're a fan
if you're you know anyone watching this
is probably a fan of developer x i won't
use a name but any any given developer
well let's say little games there you go
then pray on me um if you're a fan of
biffle games they're the the people who
made you know one of our older games
like volume a lot of those people don't
work with us anymore they've moved on to
other jobs they're doing other things it
is in my best interest for you to be a
fan of the company rather than those
individuals because you'd go over and
follow so i am on some level
incentivized to create that culture
within my studio i think that happens
especially in aaa quite a lot you know
people do tend to move on a lot from
studios to the the i'm really trying to
say a specific company but the the the
game development studio you love because
they made a game you loved 10 years ago
less than 50 percent of those people are
still there like
hopefully which is the ship of theseus
exactly hopefully they've had careers
they're doing their own thing that's a
brilliant thing but there is definitely
the games industry well first of all the
games industry tried to create rock
stars by you know promoting the names of
voters in the triple a space they used
to have like
banned photos
yeah
like all the all the photos of cliff
from like
20 years ago are amazing yeah
uh i used to literally create like like
album covers of of devs piled together
but the problem was when they did that
those devs then well they got power like
those those individuals got power they
got to you know they got to be able to
negotiate their contracts they've got to
be they were stars and they got they
were they were negotiating based on that
so now yeah we do have a culture where
the average person on the street can
maybe name the creative director of a
aaa team but they can't name individuals
unless those people have you know like
yourself alone as someone who's got like
a reputation outside of the company and
and builds it up certainly so yeah i'm
i'm kind of i'm wary of the kind of the
the the camaraderie of anonymity kind of
i don't know the games industry is
terrible at basically erasing people who
leave that's something that we
consistently as an industry do in terms
of credits happens all the time like if
you're a triple a game developer and you
leave a project before it ships you
might only make it into the special
thanks section even if you've been there
for three years four years five years
whatever like it's happening
journalist who writes 10 articles about
crunch
would much prefer articles about
contract culture
and like you know we're speaking about
contracts but i know people at
aaa studios who
are so terrified that they aren't going
to be employed that they start
sabotaging each other
or they don't get certain things that
other actual employees get like some of
them get like little holiday gift bags
or whatever and the contractors don't
get anything
just like a lot of gross treatment
things for so many very experienced
positions that are only ever advertised
as contract across the whole industry i
think it's like that's a thing i wish
that you'd write about i think we could
agree then that
once again fear produces bad decisions
right so like
if yeah i'm not saying it's like
capitalism creates bad decisions but
that's the difference that's fine sure
we can
oh man we were as elevated as we wanted
to but
i i don't think any of this i don't
think the game industry would exist
outside of capitalism i would just like
to throw that out there
i think humanity made it quite a few
years before capitalism i think the
game's industry specifically
yeah like if we're if we're like
it it it is i mean it's
there's like effectively computer games
for example so i don't know if that
necessarily holds
i feel like i'm several as as we're
talking about this by the way to be
clear i'm a capitalist so i'm absolutely
grateful for this conversation
finally it's quoted
uh i think austin might be right there
that's an interesting one
are not incompatible with capitalism um
like
there's no well then you defense what
you're defining as capitalism because
we're not talking about money is it
doesn't money doesn't equal capitalism
like you can have
i'm just talking about non-centrally
planned economies uh right like i'm
saying i don't i don't see why video
games would exist
in a centrally planned economy or if
they did it would be like you'd be like
you know
historically speaking the comparisons
would be like the soviet car industry
which did not exist
i was gonna say like i i think your
point is a nuanced interesting one and
i'm sure we'd have a really good
conversation i just want to point out
because it's funny to me that one of the
most important and coolest games ever
happened because of uh it happens over
russia tetris right so like
it's true
it's true but notice but notice what
happened to his creator speaking of
credit and unpaid right he's fine he got
everything he was like no he didn't know
he was treated absolutely terrible i
love being the dumbest person on this
podcast it's just that as soon as mike
said the word capitalism i was like is
austin going to be okay and then he we
could not say anything
it is what it is it's the dynamics of
the show we are who we are
that's what we were talking about
i simply wanted to uh to to state that i
as we're kind of talking about this i'm
thinking about some of the studios that
i work with and i think austin brings up
a very valid point of
while i don't believe that most people
are inherently muhahaha mustache
twirling evil doers that are just trying
to crush people
therein lies the true danger because
people think that they're doing
something that's really good that is by
arrow of a mission
erasing people from history or
overlooking people because we're trying
to promote a team culture isn't that a
great thing to do we do team building
things it's like yes but at the same
time you go too far to one extreme and
it's it's about finding the balance of
that and
all of the studios
yeah all the students that i'm working
with that i can think of right now at
least
um
are
avidly ardently working to change their
culture because there is a shift that is
happening within in this industry that i
feel is for the better there's new blood
that's coming in and there's new
awareness that's coming in
and it is something that is genuinely
trying to it's not about the tech and
it's not about the hardware that's
changing it there's a culture shift
that's happening inside of games right
now because i'm i'm seeing this industry
become the tip of the spear and not the
butt of the arrow for where
entertainment is going
and that's exciting to me i think that
there's more people that are starting to
experience stories and
and
interactive experiences in this media
than there are in tv and film
and or at least that's becoming the
people are starting to adapt more and
it's becoming more credible and more
legitimate and i think that game studios
are stepping into that space and they're
doing it well but i do believe that
unless they they have these
conversations and they think about hey
we should probably point out the fact
that
ex-employee is the one that actually
said that would you be fair to stand up
we just want everyone to recognize this
person as opposed to
hey guys we all do this just as a team
um i think that that is a a worthy
endeavor and and and
there should be some awareness about
that but it doesn't mean it's really bad
it's an interesting point i do have to
ask is the back of an arrow called the
butt because that's amazing i made that
up on the fly i have no idea please
don't google it i hope it is
[Music]
for the purposes of this show it is
called the blood of an error
i will ban anyone in the comments i
don't get credit for that i'm coming
after all you [ __ ]
something that you said a second ago
mike keeps kicking around in my head
about the the sort of corporate
incentive to not credit people and i
find myself thinking
um there is an interesting potential
counter-argument to that because i found
myself thinking about how
the film industry when you when you hang
out with real movie buffs
and they're like oh you know i can name
every production designer that
spielberg's worked with every
cinematographer every editor every
costume designer they know them you know
they know who they are they know their
prior credits they know the you know the
the spielberg collaborations and the
non-spielberg collaborations all these
things
they can claim you know they can knock
them off totally and i and i love
uh what that to me translates to is
um when i look at a steven spielberg
film
i don't think to myself
he
singularly made this film no obviously
it's more like
he is a magnet to top talent
and so when you look over
his body of work it's like a who's who
of every top department head and b and
below seemingly throughout the whole of
cinema and so that becomes that becomes
the cool branding for him it's not oh
you might not like my next film because
we're no longer working with this editor
they've retired or whatever
it's like
you know that we get the best possible
people i don't think most people think
that way maybe not yeah maybe not and
maybe that's a maybe that's the
difference between being a film buff or
a game buff or whatever versus uh casual
observer but
that is something that happens like
we've i mean we've just done a bunch of
hiring and we've genuinely hired people
who've come to us because they want to
work with us because they you know they
like our game so we're we're seeing that
happen in real time like for our company
that we're able to hire frankly above
our pay grade you know and if someone
really
yeah and if someone really noteworthy
comes along and then you do the thing
and then they move on
you can lay claim to having collaborated
with this superstar which is a boon to
you they get to take credit for their
contribution
to the to the game it's a boon for them
it seems like
a fundamental nothing is lost in yeah i
guess
the difference oh so so the only thing
i know you wouldn't do i'm just
exploring no no no but but in terms of i
think the only major difference is in
the games industry you're talking about
a crew of hundreds of people right like
and there's i i do agree that i think
any studio who treats
sorry i think i need to know
uber it is caring
i'm sorry austin
what did you think you were drinking
just then that forced you to look into
the cup i don't know anyone's like ever
like what the [ __ ] is this because this
is my first time using one of these uh
amber amber oh yeah so good and it has
like it has like
it's not the one that parked it's heated
it'll keep your [ __ ] warm it's i have an
app now for my phone it blew
people
taking that long to drink a drink i
drink
this was given to me as a gift
italy and drink a coffee they're like
what are you sitting down for drink it
and go it's like yeah like i've never
i've never had a coffee it's tea that i
no i drink very slowly some of us
have tummy problems when we drink milk
fast i should check don't drink milk
but i love coffee
well then do you do a non-dairy let me
let me answer your question god damn it
the reason i looked down is because this
has like
a teflon lining or something inside and
i looked and it looked dry as though i
never
i don't think it is but it it looked
like there was never any liquid in here
that caught my eye because i was like
holy [ __ ] it's so you look like you were
looking into the suitcase and pulp
fiction is what you looked like you were
like seven
i will say if you drink an emma mug too
slowly when you have your tea it will
burn the milk and you'll get a little
crusty
but really selling it this episode
brought to you by this was the maiden
voyage of this the lovely tina guo gave
me this when we were recording the
anniversary journey album she showed up
to capital with this ember mug and i was
like
and i realized it's been sitting here
and i didn't have an outlet
back there and so i i neglected it and
then this morning i thought you know
trying it out this this is how it works
with giving gifts to austin they'll sit
until absolutely necessary it's like
that's been there for a year and a half
i should try it out how's the toilet
seat working out yeah let's get started
the toilet seat went into the dumpster
thank you very much because the entire
bathroom was remodeled let's see i
planted a seed the seed grew into a tree
that's how it works true yeah grow into
a whole bathroom i'd be nowhere without
choice weird shapes
that's true i should have a little
plaque like the the the baker i just
want a picture of myself a faker room
that just looks at someone at eye level
when they're seat and go you're welcome
if it helps the the the closet door
right next to the bathroom has a decal
on it courtesy of angela that says
booker dewitt detective agency so you
are quasi-credited i'll take it
yeah i gotta go we all gotta go i i uh i
can do it i can do a plug
we need to have a ten minute
conversation come out on friday it's
coming on friday all right well then
it's not gonna be out yet uh i didn't
get to drop my trivia i'm gonna do it
really fast i'm inserting this do you
know what year the company nintendo was
founded
79.
no it's a card game company so it's like
it's like the lost old as [ __ ] it was
the end of the 1800s
[Music]
i never knew that yeah and they were a
playing cards company and they
hilariously they had like no corporate
vision because over the course they tr i
was reading this article and it was
saying they they also tried making
instant rice they were a taxi service
they tried making ballpoint pens
they were basically just wandering going
we'll just put our name on whatever none
of it's working
at instant rice
september 23 1889 was when nintendo was
found
broke my brain when i read that the
other day
couldn't sign up to a website without
birthday no nothing that old should be
allowed to exist all right forgive me i
know you're bailing uh
for next week
next week it'll drop it'll drop friday
it'll drop friday the 20th
so there wait what we'll do yeah okay
that makes sense yeah so i'll say all
right let's be honest i'll see you all
next week
bye
oh my god i didn't enjoy the show hi
everyone it's a lot of uh friday
act uh austin wintery uh composing i am
too stressed out mike bithell uh
director okay bye